what's up everybody i want to talk to
you about beat frequency and to do so
let me talk to you about this air
displacement versus time graph so this
is going to give you the displacement of
the air molecules for any time at a
particular location so say you had some
speaker and it was playing a nice simple
harmonic tone and so would sound
something like this
that's 440 hertz turns out that's an a
note people use that a lot when they're
tuning instruments and whatnot so that's
what the sound would sound like and
let's say it's sending the sound out and
at a particular point one point in space
we measure what the displacement of the
air is as a function of time let's just
say we're three meters to the right of
this speaker just so we have a number to
refer to so there's air over here the
air is chilling just relaxing and then
the sound wave comes by and that causes
this air to get displaced it moves back
and forth a minuscule amount but some
amount and if we graphed that
displacement as a function of time we
would get this graph so in other words
this entire graph is just personalized
for that point in space three meters
away from this speaker so why am i
telling you this well because we know if
you overlap two waves if i take another
wave and let's just say this wave has
the exact same period as the first wave
right so i'll put these peak to peak so
you can see compare the peaks yep takes
the same amount of time for both of
these to go through a cycle that means
they have the same period so if i
overlap these in other words if i took
another speaker and i played the same
note next to it if i played it like this
i'd hear constructive interference
because these are overlapping peak to
peak valley to valley perfectly this
note would get louder if i was standing
here and listening to it and it would
stay loud the whole time it would just
sound louder the entire time
constructive interference and if i moved
that speaker forward a little bit or i
switched the leads if i found some way
to get it out of phase so that it was
destructive interference i'd hear a
softer note maybe it would be silent if
i did this perfectly and it would stay
silent or soft the whole time it would
stay destructive in other words so if
you overlap two waves that have the same
frequency i.e the same period then it's
going to be constructive and stay
constructive or be destructive and stay
destructive but here's the crazy thing
let me get rid of this what if we
overlapped two waves that had different
periods what would happen then let's
just try it out so let me take this wave
this wave has a different period look at
if i compare these two peaks these two
peaks don't line up if i'm looking over
here the distance between these two
peaks is not the same as the distance
between these two peaks it's hard to see
it's almost the same but this red wave
has a slightly longer period if you can
see the time between peaks is a little
longer than the time between peaks for
the blue wave and you might think ah
there's only a little difference here
can't be that big of a deal right it
kind of is it causes a new phenomenon
called beat frequency and i'll show you
why it happens here so if i overlap
these two so now you take two speakers
but the second speaker you play it at a
slightly different frequency from the
first what would you get let's just look
at what happens over here they start out
in phase perfectly overlapping right
peak to peak so this is constructive
this wave starts off constructively
interfering with the other wave so you
hear constructive interference that
means if you were standing at this point
at that moment in time notice this axis
is time not space so at this moment in
time right here you would hear
constructive interference which means
that those waves would sound loud sound
really loud at that moment but then you
wait this red wave's got a longer period
so it's taking longer for this red wave
to go through a cycle that means there's
going to start becoming out of phase
right the peaks aren't going to line up
anymore when this blue wave has
displaced the air maximally to the right
this red wave is gonna not have done
that yet it's gonna take a little longer
for it to try to do that so these become
out of phase now it's less constructive
less constructive less constructive over
here look at now the peaks match the
valleys this is straight up destructive
it's gonna be soft and if you did this
perfectly it might be silent at that
point you wait a little longer and this
blue wave has essentially lapped the red
wave right you waited so long the blue
wave has gone through an extra whole
period compared to the red wave and so
now the peaks line up again and now it's
constructive again because the peaks
match the peaks and the valleys match
the valleys so that point is
constructive and it's going to be loud
again so what you would hear if you were
standing at this point three meters away
you'd first at this moment in time hear
the note be loud then you'd hear it
become soft and then you'd hear it
become loud again you'd hear this note
wobble and the name we have for this
phenomenon is the beat frequency or
sometimes it's just called beats and
i don't mean you're gonna hear like dr
dre out of this thing that's not the
kind of beats i'm talking about i'm just
talking about that wobble
from louder to softer to louder actually
let me just play it let me show you what
this sounds like so if we play the a
note again
that's the a note let me play that's 440
hertz right that's a particular
frequency let me play just a slightly
different frequency i'll play 443 hertz
and you're probably like that just
sounds like the exact same thing i can't
tell the difference between the two
but if i play them both you'll
definitely be able to tell the
difference so i'm gonna play them both
now here's the four 43 hertz and here's
the 440.
you hear a wobble it starts this thing
starts to wobble so let me stop this so
that's what physicists are talking about
when they say beat frequency or beats
they're referring to that wobble and
sound loudness that you hear when you
overlap two waves that have different
frequencies this is important it only
works when you have waves of different
frequency so what if you wanted to know
the actual beat frequency what if you
wanted to know how many wobbles you get
per second so how often is it going from
constructive to destructive back to
constructive if that takes a long time
the frequency is going to be small
because there aren't going to be many
wobbles per second but if this takes a
short amount of time if there's not much
time between constructive back to
constructive then the beat frequency is
going to be large there will be many
wobbles per second how would you figure
out this beat frequency i'll call it f b
this would be how many times this goes
from constructive back to constructive
per second so if it does that 20 times
per second this thing would be wobbling
20 times per second and the frequency
would be 20 hertz so how do you find
this if you know the frequency of each
wave it turns out it's very very easy
i'm just going to show you the formula
in this video in the next video we'll
derive it for those that are interested
but in this one i'll just show you what
it is show you how to use it so the beat
frequency if you want to find it if i
know the frequency of the first wave so
if wave 1 has a frequency f1 so say that
blue wave has a frequency f1 and wave 2
has a frequency f2 then i can find the
beat frequency by just taking the
difference i can just take f1 and then
subtract f2 and it's as simple as that
that gives you the beat frequency now
you might wonder like wait a minute what
if one what if f1 has a smaller
frequency than f2 that would give me a
negative beat frequency that doesn't
make sense we can't have a negative
frequency so we typically put an
absolute value sign around this you
should take the higher frequency minus
the lower but just in case you don't
just stick an absolute value and that
gives you the size of this beat
frequency which is basically the number
of wobbles per second i.e the number of
times it goes from constructive all the
way back to constructive per second
that's what this beat frequency means
and this formula is how you can find it
now i should say to be clear we're
playing two different sound waves our
ears really just sort of gonna hear one
total wave so these waves overlap you
can do this whole analysis using wave
interference you write down the equation
of one wave you write down the equation
of the other wave you add up the two
right we know that the total wave is
going to equal the summation of each
wave at a particular point in time so at
one point in time if we take the value
of each wave and they add them up we'd
get the total wave what would that look
like what would the total wave look like
it would look like this if we just add
it up you'd get a total wave that looks
like this green dashed wave here right
over here they add up to twice the wave
and then in the middle they cancel to
almost nothing and then back over here
they add up again and so if you just
looked at the total wave it would look
something like this so the total wave
would start with a large amplitude and
then it would die out because they
become destructive and then it would
become a large amplitude again so you
see this picture a lot when you're
talking about beat frequency because
it's showing what the total wave looks
like as a function of time when you add
up those two individual waves since this
is going from constructive to
destructive to constructive again and
this is why it sounds loud
and then soft and then loud again to our
ear so what would an example problem
look like for beats let's say you were
told that there's a flute and let's say
this flute is playing a frequency of 440
hertz like that note we heard earlier
and then let's say there's also a
clarinet they play it they want to make
sure they're in tune they want to make
sure their their jam sounds good for
everyone in the audience but when they
both try to play the a note this flute
plays 440. this clarinet plays a note
and let's say we hear a beat frequency
i'll write it in this color we hear a
beat frequency of five hertz so we hear
five wobbles per second in fact if
you've ever tried to tune an instrument
you know that one way to tune it is to
try to check two notes that are supposed
to be the same you can tell immediately
if they're not the same because you'll
hear these wobbles and so you keep
tuning it until you don't hear the
wobble anymore as those notes get closer
and closer there will be less wobbles
per second and once you hear no wobble
at all you know you're at the exact same
frequency but these aren't these are off
and so the question might ask what are
the two possible frequencies
of the clarinet well we know that the
beat frequency is equal to the absolute
value of the difference in the two
frequencies so if there's a beat
frequency of 5 hertz and the flute's
playing 440 that means the clarinet is 5
hertz off from the flute so the clarinet
might be a little too high it might be
445 hertz playing a little sharp or it
might be 435 hertz might be playing a
little flat so it would have to tune to
figure out how it can get to the point
where there'd be zero beat frequency
because when there's zero beat
frequencies you know both of these
frequencies are the same but what do you
do how does it know how does the
clarinet player know which one to do you
kind of don't sometimes sometimes you
just have to test it out let's say the
clarinet player assumed all right maybe
they were a little too sharp 445 so
they're going to lower their note so
they start to tune down what will they
listen for they'll listen for less
wobbles per second so if you become more
in tune instead of
whoa whoa whoa you would hear
whoa whoa
right and then once you're perfectly in
tune whoa
and it would be perfect there'd be no
wobbles if this person tried it and
there were more wobbles per second then
this person would know oh i was probably
at this lower note because if i'm at 435
and i go to say 430 hertz that's going
to be more out of tune now the beat
frequency would be 10 hertz you'd hear
10 wobbles per second and this person
would know immediately whoa that was a
bad idea i must not have been too sharp
i must have been too flat so now that
you know you're a little too flat you
start tuning the other way so you can
raise this up to 440 hertz and then you
would hear zero beat frequency zero
wobbles per second a nice tune and you
would be playing in harmony so recapping
beats or beat frequency occurs when you
overlap two waves that have different
frequencies this causes the waves to go
from being constructive to destructive
to constructive over and over which we
perceive as a wobble in the loudness of
the sound and the way you can find the
beat frequency is by taking the
difference of the two frequencies of the
waves that are overlapping